the leaders of germany france and
ukraine have called on russia to pull
its troops back from the ukrainian
border
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
proposed a summit that would also
include moscow which kev fears is
preparing an invasion
the conflict dates back to 2014 when
ukraine's pro-russian president was
ousted in a popular uprising
moscow-backed separatists have occupied
the eastern donbass region and crimea
ever since russia says its recent
military buildup is a response to nato
threats and ukrainian provocations
ukraine is gearing itself up for battle
the country's military is in better
shape than it was during the war in 2014
but its firepower is no match for
russia's military might
we are preparing we have a saying
if you want peace always be prepared for
war
we are ready to meet an enemy on our
land
the current build-up of troops along the
ukrainian-russian border
has been described by the u.s and nato
as the largest there since 2014
a cause of great concern for the
ukrainians
as there is no split between danger of
information war
and danger of physical war usually
russians
combine both these threats and now we
see
because tension is raising how the voice
heart voice of kremlin is also
became more dangerous for ukraine and
there are direct threats
president zielenski has appealed to
european leaders
to call on russia to pull its troops
back from the ukrainian border
it's not only our problem that is the
safety of europe
if when all the europe will understand
that it's safety
for all europe and will
will move together very quick zelinski
met
emmanuel macron in paris and angela
merkel
joined by videolink zielinski proposed a
summit that also included moscow
but so far russia has refused calls to
pull back
leaving ukraine fearful of an open
invasion